tiens toi bien là lanvin plutôt rare
gérard cd qu'ils ont mouton noir et en
costume gris fait le point sur sa vie un
peu en quarantaine à 40 ans il quitte sa
pré retraite pour lunettes
face à face d'homme à homme là on va
informer en question chez ardisson
une question qu'on me pose depuis
longtemps lanvin c'est son vrai nom
ouais ouais
serge avait un nom et j'ai dû me faire
un prénom ce2
[Applaudissements]
après tu as peur des journalistes
concert on peut dire je pense que le
travail d'un acteur n'est pas de se
raconter
au contraire d'accord il ya beaucoup
trop d'acteurs qui se raconte et quand
je les vois se raconter je crois plus à
ce qu'il faut j'essaye de ne pas faire
comme qui nous tue fait qu'au lancement
en ce moment je vais sortir un film
enfin je vais sortir un film lellouche
va sortir un film dans lequel ils
battront donc je vais attaquer cette
formation infernale car la promotion
lellouche yen est infernal en général
ils mois 7,7 pas chez nous pour nous
parce qu'on a nettement l'impression si
c'est pas que ça me fait chier c'est que
la promotion c'est de la vente et la
vente je les fais sur les marchés mais
je me rendais pas moins et c'est très
embêtant de seconde soit c'est à dire
c'est toujours très compliqué d'aller
dire aux gens n'aiment voir sinon vous
allez rater la faire d'autres vies et
j'attends impatiemment
enfin on invite les metteurs en scène a
parlé des acteurs et pas forcément que
ce soit toujours les acteurs qui parle
des metteurs en scène et nord à 40
berges
il en est où le de niro français à 40
berges il en est la même il a la même
angoisse quand il avait 30
c'est à dire est ce qu'on va vouloir de
se donner aux français comme tu dis
demain matin et moi au cinéma il ya
longtemps qu'ils nous a pas fait marcher
l'ombre et ça c'est de la faute de blanc
depuis qu'on a dit à blanc si tu veux
qu'il était génial
une fois qu'il a fait le film de blier
il a cru qu'il était pas génial en
écrivant marche à l'ombre alors que
finalement le film de blier
c'est quoi c'est une réussite formidable
parce qu'il ya un casting exact mais le
casting exact il vient du fait que blanc
avait fait marcher à l'ombre car c'est
la suite de son rôle de marshall ouen un
bon car si tu le quittes à new york avec
moi qui le protégeait dans ce film
moi je reste parce que je suis fou
amoureux la femme de manu katché
il revient à paris rencontre new
possible et puis voit débouler depardieu
gros possible aussi et puis lui arrive
ça mais c'est la suite du film de qu'il
a fait seulement quand il a fait son
film lui a rien dit on le rien donné on
m'a même pas dit c'était formidable en
tant que l'écriture
et puis quand il a fait le film de blier
on a dit au génie donc il ya sûrement
dans la tête de michel blanc un problème
dont je bâtis puisqu'on n'a pas pu faire
la suite moi c'est vrai que pour ta
pièce à la michodière l'intérieur pintât
loges c'est parce que tu comptais rester
si bon coup là non j'avais pas mal aux
joies même pas ce que c'était une
pissotière et que c'est bien de
travailler dans une pissotière notant
qu'elle soit repeinte moi tu as dit que
ton vrai métier c'était vivre enfin
l'impression c'est comme ça que la
plante et agathois souvent quand même
c'est à dire carrière c'est un mot
qu'emploient les gens quand tu es mort
je n'ai jamais figé pourquoi les acteurs
ou les comédiens parlait avec une
certitude de leur carrière dire la
différence fondamentale c'est de savoir
qu'on a une combine entre les mains
c'est pour une raison pour la faire mal
mais en aucun cas c'est un métier
la preuve c'est qu'aujourd'hui je suis
chômeur donc ce métier il est à moteur
action en dehors de ça c'est un blaireau
qui est dans une équipe de tournage
comme les autres et donc carrière ça
veut rien dire pour moi je crois que je
disais il ya des gens qui passent leur
vie à la vivre d'autres à la raconter
moi je passe ma vie à la vive et parce
que quand tu as fait après retraite dans
les landes en chevaux
preuve et c'est d'ailleurs un peu ma
guerre des très hautes très très hot
c'est pour ça qu'on ne voit pas les
genres bon fond tours fc le caravaning
cascades ricard et avec jennifer et les
gosses le sol appel pâtés de sable quoi
c'est sa clique donc un jour j'ai fait
un interview dans paris match et comme
journaliste de presse écrite sont assez
spéciaux quand il résume j'avais été à
rome toujours etc ont prié de la femme
alors j'adore ma femme et j'ai vu un
énorme camion américain passé mais un
camion tu vois qu'il fait bander
vraiment un camion avec quatre chambres
cuisine celle le bafin tout et j'ai dit
à la journaliste qui était là j'ai dit
voilà ça c'est un délire de foot camion
comme ça tu fais le tour du monde j'aime
pas le bateau
sinon je ferais comme les remis mais
j'aime pas le bateau alors lui roux tu
vois direction assistée stéréo à
l'intérieur un vrai karkwa et elle elle
avait raconté que en fait j'avais une
envie c'était de faire du camping
caravaning
ça n'a rien à voir le camion il vaut 350
plaque celui que veut donc c'est quand
même
tu vois ce que je veux dire non parce
que dans le louche défunt designer whey
un mime il est justement là j'ai alors
là j'ai j'ai été vraiment super heureux
parce que j'ai conduit des vrais qui a
mis bon et conduire un camion c'est une
folie et je comprends les mecs leurs
tripes maintenant et leur façon
d'exister par rapport à ça il ya même
des femmes qui sont bien ça et qu'ils
ont et qu'ils expliquent dans france au
pied parce que j'ai lu souvent france
août et pour me préparer à ça et c'est
vrai que leur leur témoignage et leur
façon de vivre
quant au volant d'un camion qui a dix
huit vitesses quand tu es au volant d'un
camion qui a la possibilité de faire des
millions de kilomètres
tout d'un coup un sentiment de liberté
ici et la liberté
c'est ce qu'on a plus mature got pas que
jennifer la femme est arrêté sa carrière
de chanteuse pour toi elle chante pour
moi en tout cas dans la nature pour que
tu nous dis rien sur l'eau jaune les
couches-culottes la forêt amazonienne la
faim dans le monde
j'en oublie j'en ai oublié mais enfin
pourquoi moi je trouve que le monde est
ce un spectacle a regardé par un
problème à résoudre
on est des petits blaireaux et fils et
c'est à regarder tout ça à prier pour
que ça change mais la nature de manger
des castors ou sauvant un arbre c'est
tout ce que j'ai à dire là dessus quand
ils flippent l'un ne doit pas vendre
pointe chez retourner chez moi je ne
vendrai rien non non j'ai pas le temps
de crise
et j'ai pas envie de couper sur tout et
si le cinéma était un truc qui me
faisait flipper j'arrêterai tout tout
tout de suite parce que tu as fait mieux
ou moins bien que d'imaginer ya 20 ans
nettement mieux bon tu content pour toi
est alors dans dix ans qui doit
commencer dans dix ans je me lavoie
belle voix la voix belle il va falloir
de travailler encore et dans dix ans
tout ça me ferait rigoler quoi j'espère
au fond tout misé jouvet une carrière ça
te contre 40 ans oui c'est vrai il a
fallu en attendant manger mais pour
l'instant j'ai rien fait et j'en ai
jusqu'à 50 ans justement entre 40 et 50
en principe il ya des beaux rôles je le
sais parce que je vois bohringer
travaillèrent dit y travailler
donc je dis au metteur en scène que
maintenant j'ai 40 ans et quand la
caméra s'arrête lui continue à nous
faire le héros bien sûr eh bien ça pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de 1h10 tube
abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus